في خطابات الحرب تقول روايه الجيش ببساطه
انه يخوض حربا فرضت عليه من قبل الفريق
حميتي لسيطره على السلطه والبلاد وهو مخطط
يجد دعما خارجيا وبهذا المعنى يقول الجيش
ان حربه هي حرب من اجل الحفاظ على كيان
الدوله السودانيه يسميها الجيش حرب
الكرامه ربما كرامه الجيش على نحو اخص فهو
الذي سمح بنمو هذه القوات حتى حدثت نفسها
باكله ولا يعدم الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو
حيله في تاسيس خطاب يمنح حربه معنى
ومشروعيه اخلاقيه فهو يقول انه يقاتل من
اجل سودان جديد ان التزامنا بمبادئ واهداف
الثوره المجيده والتاسيس للحكم المدني
الديمقراطي وبناء مؤسسه عسكريه جديده وجيش
مهني واحد ليست تكتيك او مناوره وانما هي
امان الهنوفي بها
ثم يزيد كيل توعد لمن يسميهم الفلول وهم
انصار نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
اننا نعيد التاكيد وبالصوت العالي انه لا
مكان للنظام البائت والفلول بيننا بعد
اليوم
ومثل هذا الخطاب انشاته حاجه حميدتي الى
اكساب حربه محتوى اخلاقيا نبيلا وما كان
ذلك شانه من قبل مع القوه المدنيه في
مسيرتها الوعره لتاسيس انتقال ديمقراطي
فما اكثر ما ازرى حماتي بتلك القوه
تكلم بهذه
القوه
طبعا انا غفراء ان احنا كفره والله اثبتنا
انا نحن غفراء
معقول زول انت حاميه انت حارس ويقول لك يا
اخي يعني انا خسم رصيدك السياسي شنو الان
يؤخذ على خطاب حميد الجديد في صياغته
الديمقراطيه المدنيه الطامحه الى تاسيس
السودان متجاوز لسودان سته وخمسين اي دوله
ما بعد الاستقلال ان تاريخه لا يؤهله لهذه
المهمه فقوات الدعم السريع جيء بها اصلا
لضرب حركات دارفور صاحبه شعارات اصلاح
الدوله السودانيه اصلاحا جذريه وما زكى
الدعم السريع لدى الرئيس المعزول عمر
البشير الا بسبب ادائه لهذه المهمه على
اكمل وجه اي التصدي لمن يطالبون بسودان
جديد صنيع حمايه اليوم
[موسيقى]
عشان نحسم التمرد في السودان
والشباب جاهزين
بعد ثلاثه اشهر ويزيد من الحرب التي احدثت
دمارا واسعا في البنيه التحتيه لعاصمه
البلاد الخرطوم بما يقدر بعشرات المليارات
من الدولارات وبعد تشريد الملايين من سكان
العاصمه ما بين نازح داخليا ولاجئ في دول
الجوار وبعدما وقع من انتهاكات جسيمه
للمواطنين باحتلال دورهم وضربهم واذلالهم
ونهب ممتلكاتهم سيكون الوعد بالمدنيه
والديمقراطيه مدعاه للخوف للترحيب فقط راى
الناس في العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مدينه
الجنينه في غرب السودان مناظر من العرض
الديمقراطي كيف يكون
حيث يتهم الدعم السريع بارتكاب مجازر كانت
محل ادانه دوريه ويواجه الجيش كذلك اشكالا
في تاسيس خطاب الحرب فاذا صحت مقولته حول
كونها من اجل صون كيان الدوله السودانيه
فان مسؤوليته عن الرعايات المخدقه على
قوات الدعم السريع والمتراضيه عن توسعها
وتضخمها وتزيين صورتها وصوره قائدها تجعل
من الحرب ثمنا باهظا لا مناصب الجيش من
دفعه
اما القوه المدنيه السودانيه التي كان اول
ظهور لها بعد الحرب في العاصمه الاثيوبيه
بعد طواف بعضها على تشاد ويوغندا فهي
الاخرى تعيش مازق خطابها خاصه بعد التسرب
مقولاتها في الديمقراطيه والحكم المدني
لتشكل جزءا من ادبيات الدعم السريع على
لسان قائده حميتي اما مازقها الاخر فهو
تغضيها شان العسكر عن نمو الدعم السريع
الذي يحاربه اليوم
وتحاشيها ان تنظر اليه بوصفه منتجا
انقاذيه وكان عجز الجيش عن تفكيك بنيه
الدعم السريع العسكريه كعجز لجنه تفكيك
النظام عن المساس بامبراطوريته الماليه
لمن الغد ربما يكون للاتين بوعي جديد
لمعنى الوطن ومعنى السياسه ومعنى العسكريه